let's go next to logan from kenosha
wisconsin logan you're on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
all right
sorry i'm in the car i just got out of
class you're doing great so i was just
calling to ask a question about 2024
sure um
do you think it might be better if it
was trump running
considering the
idea of turnout to vote against trump
like in 2020 it was more of a
vote against trump than for biden you're
saying would it be better for democrats
if trump was the nominee right
for democrats like
personally i think it would be worse for
democrats if it was like desantis or
someone like that so here's my thought
this is a really good question
if it's biden versus trump
i think trump wins
if it's kamala versus trump i think
trump wins i think the one way that it's
better for democrats if it's trump
is if there's an actual
sort of more inspiring
and dynamic democratic nominee i don't
know who that would be i don't even know
if the person exists but my point here
is
i think if it's seen as a rematch of
2020
i think trump wins if it's
tired old crazy trump again
versus
someone else that's interesting i think
in that case it's better for democrats
but it's very very risky it's a risky
proposition
right
all right well
thanks for taking my call all right
logan from kenosha great to hear from
you
that's gonna do it for our calls today
we will take calls again next week and i
look forward to hearing from you then